IT'S TIME FOR "DOUBLE DOUBLE
TOIL AND TROUBLE."
A FORMER INTERN OF MARY-KATE AND
ASHLEY OLSEN'S COMPANY HAS FILED
A LAWSUIT AGAINST THEM, CLAIMING
SHE WORKED 50-HOUR WEEKS UNDER
HORRIBLE CONDITIONS.
HEY, GUYS, CUT IT OUT!
THE INTERN CLAIMED, AMONG OTHER
THINGS, THAT SHE HAD TO GO TO
THE HOSPITAL FOR DEHYDRATION
AFTER CARRYING 50 POUNDS OF
TRENCHCOATS IN 100-DEGREE
WEATHER, LIKE YOU DO.
AND THAT WAS JUST FOR ONE OF
MARY-KATE'S "SUMMER FRIDAY"
OUTFITS.
IT MAY NOT BE GLAMOROUS SLAVING
FOR TWO POCKET WITCHES, BUT AT
LEAST IT GOES ON YOUR RESUME.
COMEDIANS, WHAT ARE SOME
TERRIFYING RESPONSIBILITIES
YOU'D LIST ON YOUR LINKEDIN
PROFILE FROM YOUR TIME AS AN
OLSEN INTERN?
IN 60 SECONDS AND BEGIN.
DOUG BENSON.
>> LEARNING TO KNOW WHICH ONE IS
ASHLEY AND WHICH ONE IS NOT
ASHLEY.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS.
MICHELLE.
>> FIND SOME OLD FRENCH DUDES
THEY CAN MARRY.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. DOUG.
>> GETTING THEM DOWN WHEN THEY
GET STUCK IN A TREE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MOSHE KASHER.
>> TUCKING THEM INTO THEIR
COFFINS AT NIGHT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MICHELLE.
>> GIVE THEM THEIR HOURLY BOTOX
INJECTIONS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MOSHE KASHER.
>> RENEWING DAVE COULIER'S
RESTRAINING ORDER.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
DOUG.
>> YOU HAVE TO WATCH ALL OF
THEIR STRAIGHT TO VHS MOVIES
INCLUDE "PASSPORT TO PARIS."
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HOW DO YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
CALLED, DOUG?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> CHRIS: GOOD ANSWER.
MICHELLE.
>> CHEW UP ALL THEIR FOOD AND
FEED IT TO THEM MAMA BIRD STYLE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
DOUG.
>> 24-HOUR SAGET WATCH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.